in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 28th, on which we commemorate, our venerable
Father Paul of Xeropotamo, founder of the monasteries of Xeropotamo and Saint Paul on Mount
Athos.
Our Father Paul was, it is said, the Son of Emperor Michael I rangabeh, in the years
811 through 813, and of Procopia, the eminent daughter of Emperor Nikiforos I, and was named
Procopius in Holy Baptism.
At the deposition of Michael I, he was made a unic by order of Leo the Armenian.
He gave himself from his earliest age to the study of the Holy Scriptures and the composition
of sacred hymns, and acquired such a reputation for his knowledge that he was nicknamed the
Consul of Philosophers.
He secretly nourished the desire to abandon the pleasures of the world and riches and glory
to follow the way traced out by the Holy Father's.
Having finally made his decision, he changed his rich garments for those of a beggar and left
the capital in secret to hasten like a thirsty deer to the holy mountain of Athos.
He settled near the monastery that today is called Xeropotamo, and that had been originally
founded by Empress Paul Heria, but had been destroyed by a serocene incursion.
He built a little cell there in which he spent his days and nights in continual prayer.
Nearby lived the Holy Hermit Cosmos, who conferred on him the monastic tensor under the name
of Paul.
After this event, he gave himself with redoubled order to all the struggles for virtue.
He fasted and prayed as if he were an incorporeal angel.
His bed was the hard earth, his pillow a stone, and in place of manual work, he shed copious
tears and had love and a profound humility towards everyone.
He soon became known and admired by the fathers of Athos.
As his kinsmen, Emperor Romanos Lecapinos, in the years 920-944, sought him everywhere.
He was finally discovered and presented to return to Constantinople to see his kinsfolk
again.
The poor monk dressed in rags was received as an earthly angel by the princes and great
ones of the land.
He healed the Emperor, who was ill by his prayer, and the laying on of his hands, and remained
some time in the capital at the sovereign's request to teach his two sons, without however
modifying his rule and manner of life.
When Paul judged that it was time for him to return to the Holy Mountain, the Emperor
gave him gold and workmen in abundance to rebuild Pujeria's monastery, and sometime later,
he sent his son, Thelfi Lactus, who was at that time patriarch to consecrate the Church.
When he was about to leave, the Emperor also gave him a priceless fragment of the Holy Cross
to be placed forever in the sanctuary of the monastery.
It was not long before numerous monks gathered at the monastery to practice virtue there
and St. Paul desiring a more solitary life, retired to the foothills of Athos, in an isolated
spot that belonged to the monastery, yet even there disciples came to join him.
A new monastery was built, a little in from the coast, to protect it from the frequent
incursions of pirates, and was dedicated to St. George, but it is the custom today to call
it by the name of St. Paul, its founder.
Having been warned by God of the day of his death, St. Paul gathered the brethren of his two
monasteries together, and exhorted them to follow his teaching to the shedding of blood
if necessary.
Then, his eyes bathed in tears, he asked forgiveness of them all, stood up, clothed himself
in his mandias, monastic cloak, and received the holy mysteries.
His face became as radiant as the sun, so that all present fell to the ground, incapable
of bearing such radiance.
After pronouncing the prayer of St. Johnicus, which it was his custom to recite, my hope is
the Father, my refuge is the Son, my protection is the Holy Spirit, O Holy Trinity, glory
to thee.
He stretched out his hands, and his eyes turned heavenward, gave his soul into God's hands.
His remains, taken by boat, according to his instructions, to be buried on the peninsula
of Scythonia, were miraculously transferred to Constantinople, where it was possible for
all the people to venerate them.
The prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save
us.